[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen hier bei Bild Mensch der
läuft und läuft und läuft der VW Käfer
das ist das Bild des deutschen
Wirtschaftswunders Millionen Autos die
vom Band laufen immer mehr davon
deutscher Wohlstand und das hier das ist
das Bild der deutschen Autokrise
tausende Mercedes Fabrik neu geparkt auf
einem Flughafen bei Bremen
Lieferprobleme außerdem Energiekrise und
immer neue Umweltauflagen der Kampf ums
Auto wird unsere Industrie hier gerade
der erdigt die richtigen Fragen an diese
Gäste heute Abend dann Kai Ebel nämlich
so viele Jahre der deutsche Formel 1
Reporter Antje carpek grünen
verkehrsexpertin aus Berlin sie will die
Verkehrswende weg vom Auto Frank
Schäffler
Bundestagsabgeordneter der FDP die den
Verkehrsminister stellt außerdem
Professor Andreas Knie
mobilitätsforscher er will das aus das
Verbrenners am liebsten sofort und
Thomas Koch ex-daimler Ingenieur und
Maschinenbau Professor er glaubt ganz
Schwestern die Zukunft des Verbrenners
und sagt wir Deutschen wir verlieren
gerade die
Weltmarktführerschaft beim Auto in allen
herzlich willkommen hier bei Bild ja
Herr Ebel wir haben ihn ein Bild
mitgebracht das müssten Sie eigentlich
kennen schauen wir mal drauf das ist ein
ganz besonderes Auto was ist das und wem
gehört es
ist ein Auto dieses Typs ich glaube dass
ich so ein Auto fahre aber ich glaube
nicht dass das meiner ist aber es ist
ein Auto weil das den Unterschied sehe
ich schon würden Sie sagen sie lieben
das Ding auch ich mag schon sehr gerne
ist schon schön so ein Pferdchen ja was
empfinden Sie rein gefühlsmäßig wenn Sie
den Motor da richtig losheulen lassen ja
jetzt nicht das pure Glück also ich
komme da eher so vom Äußeren her und da
ist von hedonistischer Ansatz ich finde
es einfach ich bin Sportwagen sehen
einfach schön aus es war bei mir auch
nicht immer so aber wenn man 30 Jahre
mit dem Formel 1 um die Welt reist dann
weiß man plötzlich die Schönheit eines
Autos zu schätzen aber das ist schon
eine emotionale Sache für ja ja ja wie
gesagt
Ferrari-Chef immer we don't say cars we
sell dreams und da ist was dran da könnt
einfach ein Traum und kein Auto könnten
sie sich ein Leben komplett ohne Auto
vorstellen aus gehen alles nur im Moment
sehe ich das nicht so oder oder würde
das nicht so gerne haben weil so ein
Auto ist hin und wieder auch mal
praktisch auch wenn ich jetzt abends zum
Beispiel immer gerne ohne Auto unterwegs
bin also zu Hause mache ich eigentlich
fast alles zu Fuß zumal ich auch beim
Abendessen immer gern Gläschen trinke
also da gehört auch nicht dazu wenn sie
unbedingt sein muss nehme ich auch nicht
mit aber aber manchmal ist es einfach
nötig und das funktioniert auch relativ
gut im Gegensatz zu anderen
bewegungsmitteln in Deutschland
Emotionen die werden über Autos spricht
wir können Ihnen das Ding von Kebe
gerade nochmal zeigen so ein Ferrari wie
er fährt in Schlamm grau im übrigen
was empfinden Sie beim Anblick wenn sich
kein reinsetzen
also ich habe irgendwo mal in einer
leidenpsychologischen Zeitschrift
gelesen das Autos angeblich das gleiche
fällt im Gehirn anregen dass für
Sexualität zuständig ist bei mir bewegt
das wenig Emotionen außer dass ich denke
sie teuer aus bei ihnen bewegt das wenig
Emotionen also sie würden sich nicht
gerne reinsetzen ihre Kinder auch nicht
möglicherweise zumindest eine Probefahrt
mit Kabel also ich bin indifferent mir
ist das relativ wurscht ob ich da drin
sitze oder nicht macht für mich kein
Unterschied meine Kinder möchte ich da
definitiv nicht drin haben vielleicht
mal sagen dass ich kein erotisches
Verhältnis mit meinem Auto das ist gut
dass du das geklärt hast
er sich ein Leben ohne Auto vorstellen
können sie leben das im Grunde
ja im Grunde lebe ich das natürlich
braucht man wenn man ganz super kleine
Kinder hat auch ab und zu mal ein Auto
jetzt meine Kinder zum Glück nicht mehr
super klein ja ich war voll berufstätig
und es war so teilweise mit dem Hin und
Her chauffieren von Säuglingen ins
Parlament und dann noch einen kita-kind
das war manchmal schwierig ich kann das
verstehen wenn Familien sagen so die
ersten drei Jahre gerade wenn man
vielleicht nicht in der Großstadt lebt
schaffe ich es nicht ohne es gibt
Menschen die aus irgendwelchen Gründen
auch sagen für mich ist es wirklich
schwer ohne Autor habe ich totales
Verständnis für aber ich kann mir Leben
ohne Auto super gut vorstellen ich habe
nämlich ein Elektromoped und das ist das
löst bei mir Gefühle aus
der Großstadt hier in Berlin rumfahren
Professor Andreas Knie bei uns der Knie
ein Leben ohne Auto ist das für sie
zumindest in den Städten erstrebenswert
nein ohne Auto soll es ja nicht sein wir
brauchen nur weniger Autos wir haben zu
viel vom gleichen wir haben viele tolle
Autos aber was zu viel ist ist zu viel
und wir haben es übertrieben und gerade
großen Städte verzichten wir fahren alle
Moderator
mit verzichten sie ja mehr gewinnen also
das Auto war für uns alle Freiheit also
wir sind ja alle in so einer Generation
wie ich fast sagen wo das Auto wirklich
noch so ein Vehikel war raus ich komme
auch wie viele oder fast immer alle aus
dem Dorf und haben sich dann
rausgefahren mit dem Auto jetzt ist
Freiheit aber Kabel hat schon angedeutet
für mich kein eigenes Auto zu haben
sondern das was ich gerade nutzen will
auch zu nutzen das manchmal die Füße
manchmal das Rad manchmal das kleine
manchmal hat gesagt wir wollen weniger
sie wollen weniger Autos in den Städten
also irgendjemand muss ja jetzt dann
doch verzichten
Millionen Autos wir sind 82 Millionen
Menschen und davon können viele Menschen
nicht fahren das heißt also statistisch
hat jeder fast drei und wenn jeder nur
eins hätte hätten wir schon ganze Menge
weniger und ich brauche mal ein Auto
nicht und wenn man jetzt mal genau guckt
auf die statistisch sind 92% der Zeit
steht ein Auto und wenn es fährt hat es
eine Besetzungsgrad von 1,01 das können
wir besser Herr Scheffler können Sie sie
stellen mit der FDP den Verkehrsminister
garantieren dass wir in Zukunft weniger
Autos bekommen werden wie er Knie das
sagt oder dass das Auto weiterhin riesen
gegen Stellenwert in Deutschland haben
vielleicht findet das Auto darf man
nicht verteufeln ziel ist es richtig
dass mehr Menschen durchschnittlich mit
einem Auto fahren sollten also das waren
das versucht effizienter zu machen drei
Autos glaube ich ist richtig sie haben
auch mehrere zumindest der Scheffler ich
habe einen Oldtimer
und da meine Frau auch berufstätig ist
und jeden Tag 100 km hin und her fahren
muss braucht man eben mehr aber ich habe
auch ein Elektrofahrzeug weil ich glaube
dass das durchaus auch etwas ist was man
schon was man muss genau kann ja gerade
angesprochen hat ja aber das meine ich
ja unproblematisch dann wenn dieses
Fahrzeug nicht bewegt wird dann hat es
ja auch keine Emissionen also insofern
ist das ja kein schaden aber ich glaube
im ländlichen Bereich ist eben das
Automobil oftmals unverzichtbar denn
wenn ich bei mir ein Ostwestfalen von
Stemwede nach Minden zur Arbeit fahren
muss dann kann ich das nicht mit
öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln und das
wird wahrscheinlich auch naher Zukunft
nicht so sein denn dafür sind die ja ist
die
Bevölkerungsdichte dort einfach zu
gering damit sich das rechnet in
Deutschland ist längsten Kampf ums Auto
entbrannt so haben wir diese Sendung ja
auch genannt immer weniger Autos günstig
Andreas Knie und das scheint sich im
Moment ganz viele in der Politik zu
wünschen es gibt immer mehr
Schreckensmeldung deshalb in den
vergangenen Wochen und Monaten aus der
deutschen autowirtschaft
11 mai der Autozulieferer Fino
automotive mit Sitz in Eberswalde ist
insolvent 25 Juli der Augsburger
Automobilzulieferer Burscheid und wenig
meldet Insolvenz an betroffen sind 300
Angestellte 8 September der
Automobilzulieferer dr Schneider aus
Oberfranken hat einen Insolvenzantrag
gestellt rund 2000 Beschäftigte sind
betroffen 2 Oktober das Hamburger
Unternehmen Ibero hat einen
Insolvenzantrag gestellt die Firma
stellt Sensoren für die Autoindustrie
her 20 Oktober der
nordrhein-westfälische Auto Zulieferer
Burgers hat Insolvenz angemeldet das
Unternehmen stellt Verkleidungen
Dämpfungen und Isolationen her mit mehr
als 6000 Mitarbeitern Achter November
der Auto Zulieferer Schäffler gibt
bekannt Abbau von 1.300 Stellen Grund
der schnellere Wandel hin zur
Elektromobilität 18 November die Firma
biag GmbH in Bruchsal stellt ihre
Produktion ein die Firma mit 154
Angestellten Produzent des BMW
Kühlergrills und des mercedes-sterns
der Mercedes-Stern Herr Koch das ist ja
ja sozusagen eins der größten Symbole
überhaupt der deutschen
Automobilindustrie das kleine Werk das
diesen Stern herstellt hat jetzt die
Produktion einstellen müssen fertig
gerade was ordentlich gegen die Wand in
der deutschen Autoindustrie ja und das
sind ja erst die Vorboten die wir hier
vernehmen die Firma die ist im
mercedes-benz-stern im Hersteller hat
noch eine neue galvanisierungsanlage
investiert hier werden insbesondere die
hohen Energiekosten dieser Firma
letztendlich den Chaos machen ich hoffe
dass die Firma überlebt wie viele andere
auch aber es sind wahnsinnig viele
mittelständische Betriebe die momentan
am Existenzminimum an der Grenze
mittlerweile existieren müssen ich mache
mir größtes Sorgen wie diese Firmen
teilweise über den Winter kommen und ich
hoffe sehr dass ich eine Lösung gehen
wird dass wir diesen Firmen die
teilweise
Weltmarktführer sind ihren Segmenten die
wirkliche Champions versteckte Champion
sind die Dinge können die anderen noch
nicht können glauben
noch nachkommt was befürchten sie ich
befürchte dass wenn es so weitergeht
dass gerade die Zulieferbetriebe der
zweiten dritten viertenordnung also
nicht die ganz großen die leiden auch
die kontinentals die chefler sie genannt
wurden aber die dahinter sind die
zuzuliefern die Firmen die kämpfen hat
Jahren jetzt kommen noch die
Energiekosten Ordnung worüber reden wir
da wie viele Firmen wie viel
Arbeitsplätze wie viel Stellen sind dort
in Gefahr ich kann ihn nicht die genaue
Zahl sagen aber die verschiedenen
Aussagen die man hört sind das teilweise
bis zu ähm also hohe fünfstellige
Beträge an Arbeitnehmern gefährdet sind
und das schlimme ist das sind ja hoch
bezahlte
IG Metall Tarifverträge das sind
Menschen die ein hohes Einkommen haben
und es nicht nur Leute die für 12 € in
ihrer Arbeit völlig in 13 € sondern
wirklich auch toll verdienen und damit
auch wiederum das Geld weiterleiten und
dann in ihren sozialgemeinschaften auch
wiederum für
florierendes Geschäft beim Blumenhändler
etc sorgen und die fallen weg und das
ist dramatisch ihr Leben ist die
Automobilindustrie sie sind Daimler
Ingenieur sie haben ganz viele Patente
sind sozusagen autoerfinder in ihrer
Biografie wenn Sie jetzt auf die
Automobilindustrie auf diese aktuelle
Krise schauen wie viel davon ist
hausgemacht also ich würde es gerne
präsentieren dürfen ich war dann 10
Jahre in untertür kam habe dort
nutzfahrzeugmotoren entwickelt in dem
ganz fantastischen Team wir waren bei
jeder Emissionsstufe wirklich
Weltmeister wir haben das ganz ganz toll
gemacht mit einer tollen Mannschaften
seit 9 Jahren darf ich eben in Karlsruhe
Institut für Technologie das ganze
Themenfeld der Antriebstechnik eben in
Forschung und Lehre vertreten und ähm
wir leiden alle drunter das seit vielen
vielen Jahren dieses Themenfeld
nachhaltige umweltfreundliche
Antriebstechnik mit Verbrennungsmotoren
auch als moderne Hybride das ist kein
Stellenwert man hat da gab es
tatsächlich auch
verschiedenen Frau Carpe wenn Sie das
Hören für das Verbrenner aus ja ganz
wichtiges Ziel jetzt auch der aktuellen
Bundesregierung vor allen Dingen der
Grünen auch auf EU-Ebene das Verbrenner
aus beschlossen jetzt wie viel
Arbeitsplätze nehmen Sie dafür in Kauf
beschlossen wir wollen natürlich
überhaupt nicht das Arbeitsplätze
vernichtet werden sondern im besten Fall
werden diese Arbeitsplätze transformiert
und ich finde das natürlich
ausgesprochen bedauerlich dass jetzt
gerade so viele Firmen Insolvenz
anmelden sie keine Verantwortung das hat
nichts mit ihrer Politik zu tun oder das
ist ja eine Entwicklung die sich in den
letzten produzieren in den letzten zwei
drei Jahren
entwickelt hat bzw ja und strukturelles
Problem hat zum einen haben wir durch
die corona-pandemie erste
Schwierigkeiten gehabt dann hat mir die
Zulieferer kettenschwierigkeiten jetzt
haben wir steigende Energiepreise und so
weiter das sind alles Herausforderungen
die bestimmte Unternehmen einfach nicht
mehr packen weshalb ich finde dass es
Verantwortung von Politik ist hier zu
schauen wie man möglichst vielen
Unternehmen auch unter die Arme greifen
kann ich finde das diese aktuelle Krise
die ähm ganz viele Unternehmen unter
immense Herausforderungen stellt darf
man nicht gegen das allgemeine Thema
ausführen das allgemeine Thema ist aber
ein anderes und das haben sie gerade
wichtiger Weise gesagt es gibt in
Deutschland eine zulieferstrategie oder
eine zuliefer-pyramide die natürlichen
ganz sich eigenes Bedürfnis hat so lange
als geht die eigenen Produkte zu
verkaufen wenn jetzt aber China
beschließt dass wir in 2030 sie nur noch
Elektrofahrzeuge abnehmen wenn die
Europäische Union beschließt das ab 2035
ist nur noch Elektrofahrzeuge zugelassen
werden dann
muss dann muss finde ich auch der
deutsche Markt und auch die deutsche
Politik rechtzeitig ein Hinweis geben
dass man sich in diese Richtung
weiterentwickeln
das ich will politisch natürlich als
grundsätzliches Ziel dass wir auf
nachhaltige
Antriebsformen umsteigen aber ich will
nicht die Insolvenz von Firmen das muss
man mal klar sagen der Scheffler ist das
naiv dass man sagt einerseits will man
das und auf der anderen Seite für die
Arbeitsplätze wollen wir aber nicht
verantwortlich sein sie ja tragen das ja
mit in der aktuellen Ampel na ja aber
wir haben als FDP dafür gesorgt dass auf
europäischer Ebene das Verbrenner aus
eben nicht stattfindet sondern das ab
2035 auch synthetische Kraftstoffe
weiter
verbrannt werden dürfen in einem
Verbrennungsmotor das heißt es wird eben
kein Verbrenner ausgeben sondern
das Kernproblem ist dass man alleine auf
Elektromobilität gesetzt hat ja und da
ein industriepolischen Großversuch
gemacht hat
dessen Folgen wir jetzt eben erleben und
die Welt hört ja nicht in Europa auf
sondern jedes Mann wer hat wer hat
darauf Regierung die Grünen ja das ist
ja ein Plan gewesen der schon über viele
Jahre jetzt läuft der umgesetzt wurde
und die Industrie also vW macht nach wie
vor Gewinne oder BMW aber die machen
jetzt ihre Produktionsstätten eben im
Ausland und in Deutschland würde
Elektromobilität vorangebracht aber
Werke werden in Brasilien in Südostasien
über schnell aufgebaut und der
Verbrennermotor wird weiter existieren
und das ist im Kern ein Riesenproblem
für die Schlüsselindustrie in
Deutschland
funktioniert ja gar nicht wie
funktioniert ja nicht richtig weil wenn
man sich das ganze mal anguckt
es ist nicht richtig ausgereift ein
Verbrenner mit den sogenannten e-fuels
also mit synthetischen Kraftstoff das
würde ja funktionieren während E-Autos
die rechnen sich wenn die 200.000 km
gefahren haben solange fährt kein E-Auto
das wissen wir auch wie die Batterien
entstehen wie die entsorgt werden wie
die gelöscht werden das sind alles
riesige Probleme die wir da haben die
wir uns da auch selber schaffen dann
machen wir den eigenen Arbeitsmarkt eine
Kernkompetenz kaputt Deutschland baut
die besten Autos der Welt diese
Industrie die killen wir komplett dann
holen chinesische ja damals schon von
der großen Koalition beschlossen im
Prinzip und jetzt wird es weitergeführt
aber es muss man jetzt mal wirklich die
Kirche wieder ins Dorf bringen das ist
ein Projekt was wir seit 35 Jahren
machen ein Strukturwandel haben wir
können es natürlich so machen wie der
Kohleindustrie wie der Stahlindustrie
wieder Textilindustrie an etwas
festhalten was so nicht mehr gängig ist
wir müssen uns modernisieren und
natürlich wird immer mehr
Produktionskapazität nach China
verlagert werden immer mehr F&E
Geschichten nach China verlagert china
hat aber die die Zeichen der Zeit
erkannt und hat ganz andere
Rahmenbedingungen entwickelt das heißt
wenn wir jetzt nicht anfangen bei uns in
unseren heimatwerken endlich mal auf
etwas anderes umzustellen was sauberer
ist dann wird muss man regenerativ
erzeugen wir schaffen das nicht mehr mit
Strom wenn wir das jetzt endlich mal
schaffen endlich mal der Struktur
IG metallübung wir machen gerade
Automobilindustrie ein und kaufen
so viel Strom haben wir doch gar nicht
das Problem
erstens es ist nicht so dass die Welt
sagte Verbrenner ist schlecht das ist in
Europa sagen china hat eine ganz klare
Strategie China sagt wir wollen in
Zukunft sowohl moderne Elektrofahrzeuge
anbieten da wollen wir natürlich spitze
gehören China sagt aber auch ganz klar
wir wollen
Weltmarktführer werden bei modernen
Hybridantrieben chinesische Firma Chili
kaufen Daimler kaufen Volvo kaufen
Renault Stück für Stück auf und wollen
Weltmarktführer ab es werden rein
Batterie elektrisch
also daimler baut seine Autos noch in
China wir kaufen in Zukunft ansonsten
chinesische Verbrenner oder wie wie
sieht die Zukunft aus China kann doch
kein Vorbild sein China kann doch kein
Vorbild sein wenn man sehen dass das
Land ist das mit am meisten CO2
verbraucht und wir wollen doch gerade so
deshalb wollen
doch alle so wunderbar wenig CO2
verbrauchen auch wenn alle Autos die bis
zum heutigen Tag gebaut worden sind alle
zusammengenommen verbrauchen immer noch
weniger CO2 als damals der eher
falloutfühl für oder so ähnlich dieser
untersprechliche Vulkan
der damals die Aschewolke
hochgeschleudert hat und da gab es auch
keine Beschwerden ich sag das nur mal
dass
das Auto krass
verstehen
was passiert mit den Daimler
Arbeitsplätzen die die hier den
Verbrenner gebaut haben künftig wird in
China der Daimler Verbrenner gebaut ja
das wird alles Stück für Stück verlagert
werden wir verlagern unsere Betrieb ist
bereits heute so in diesem komplizierten
Geflecht und nicht nur die endfirma der
VW der Audi der anders ein Motor baut
sondern auch Teile zu liefern halte
zugeliefert werden müssen ist es heute
schon so dass die Firmen nicht mehr die
deutschen Zulieferer finden ja sagen ich
kann hier nicht mehr noch Geld
investieren dann
in chinesischen Firmen die dann
zuliefert Bauteile in deutschen Motoren
liefern lassen mit politischen
Beschlüssen machen wir hier unsere
Arbeitsplätze dicht und dieselben Autos
zukünftig in Shanghai gebaut man muss
jetzt aber auch mal die Geschichte von
der anderen Seite betrachten 2016 als
wir in Berlin in die Regierung gegangen
sind gesagt wir wollen unsere Busflotte
super alte Diesel Busse umstellen auf
Elektrobusse und dann haben wir einmal
gesagt wie viel brauchen wir wo kriegen
wir die her und die einzigen die in der
Lage waren Elektrobusse zu liefern weil
China haben wie gesagt das wollen wir
politisch Regierung Investition
eingesteckt haben
stimmlichen Nachteil also in der
Lautstärke wir wollten keine
chinesischen Busse wir haben gesagt wir
wollen über Daimler kaufen weil wir hier
eine Verpflichtung sehen war schwierig
weil Daimler nicht lieferfähig war weil
es an der Stelle einfach entschuldigung
aber diese Entwicklung verpennt wurde
weil sich Hamburg Berlin Niedersachsen
und Hessen zusammen getan haben und
gesagt haben wir geben Großauftrag auf
und wir halten es ein paar Jahre jetzt
mit einer Brückenlösung von Diesel
Bussen noch aus und Daimler die Chance
wir haben also keine Arbeit
produzieren die Frage gibt es doch ja
nur weil sie ein paar ankündigen zu
kaufen produzieren die ja nicht morgen
neue Fische Entschuldigung also ihr Plan
ist jetzt vor kapic sieht zwingen mit
dem Verbrenner aus die Unternehmen dazu
dann eben alternative Anfänger überhaupt
gar niemanden sondern ich habe lange im
Europäischen Parlament gearbeitet da
haben wir schon vor 20 Jahren gesagt
wenn die deutsche Industrie die
Entwicklung
verpennt verschläft nicht mitgeht dann
wird sie irgendwann ein
Wettbewerbsnachteil haben
die Verantwortung dafür geben dass die
Industrie hier nicht
entsprechend wird aber sie tragen das
alles mit herr Schäffler das heißt wir
gucken jetzt so wir zeigen noch mit ein
bisschen mit dem Finger auf die
Industrie und sagen ah die haben das
wieder verpennt die letzten 10 20 30
Jahre und so weiter aber die
Arbeitsplätze sind dann in China ja gut
wir 2016 hatten wir
noch doppelt so viel Arbeitsplätze in
Deutschland in der Automobilindustrie
als wir das heute haben und das hat
natürlich seine Ursache und die liegt
natürlich im politischen Entscheidungen
die Vorgängerregierung getroffen haben
wir haben auf als FDP ich habe schon mal
gesagt dafür gesorgt dass auf
europäischer Ebene der Verbrennungsmotor
ab 2035 nicht aus ist sondern dass er
weiter existieren kann und das finde ich
erstmal ein großer politischer Erfolg
weil diese diese technologieoffenheit
das ist ja eigentlich das fehlende das
Problem was wir aktuell haben alle haben
auf Elektromobilität gesetzt aber es
gibt ja viele es gibt ja viele andere
Antriebstechniken auch noch und warum
nutzen wir die nicht und schauen was
dann am Ende am besten funktioniert und
was ich am Markt durchsetzt das Problem
ist ja nicht dass wir
Elektrofahrzeug haben das finde ich gut
ich bin auch Vorsitzender
wissenschaftlichen Gesellschaft Kollegen
von fantastische Arbeiten neue invetter
freie Batterien neue Elektromotoren das
ist toll was dort geleistet wurde auf
der Elektromotoren Seite was mich aber
massiv stört ist und diese Zuweisung
geht in Richtung der Politik diese
verhinderungshaltung von alternativen
man muss schon ganz viel Angst haben
dass die Technologie des Elektromotors
scheitert dass man Technologien die
funktionieren können die auch nachhaltig
sind wir haben Einigkeit nachhaltigkeit
ist das was wir wollen dass wir sie
nicht ideologische Fähigkeit
Technologien die nachhaltig sind die
werden aktiv verhindert was heute und
wir haben vorher nach der Zuständigkeit
gefragt was passiert ist aktive
Klimaschutz Verhinderungspolitik in dem
wir verschiedene Lösungen die allesamt
nachhaltig sind indem er die verhindern
es ist furchtbar
also nehmen ein Beispiel wir können
neben Elektrofahrzeugen die eine
wichtige sollte der Zukunft sind können
wir auch komplett den Kraftstoff CO2
neutral stellen das geht das ist machbar
wir könnten innerhalb von zehn bis 14
Jahren da gibt es unterschiedliche
Skalierung könnten wir komplett im
gesamten Kraftstoff den wir in
Deutschland brauchen nicht mehr auf
irgend was anderes
ja das geht ja nicht heute in dem Sie
einfach ein Hebel wir sind die Debatte
führt hier das wird kein Mensch mehr die
ist echt aber das ist
einmal 20 Jahren vor 30
Jahren in Europa in nordamer
hier sitzen Daimler Ingenieur am Tisch
und der sagt ganz klar kümmert euch
nicht um das ehemaliger langjähriger
Daimler Ingenieur sitzt am Tisch und der
sagt dir kümmert euch nicht um das was
wirklich umweltfreundlich ist und das
was ideologischen Gründen also logisch
haben
Entscheidung von dir sie sprechen wann
ich die Grünen in der Bundesregierung so
und ich bin bestimmt die letzte Person
die nicht technologieoffen ist ich
glaube es gibt eine ganze Reihe von das
verändern
die ganze Reihe vom Bundespolitikern die
sich regelmäßig auch mit Antriebsarten
und antriebsstoffen auseinandersetzen
aber nehmen wir das Beispiel Wasserstoff
wird hier gerne in der Region diskutiert
weil Brandenburg so viel Flächen hat und
dann sagt ja und wo kommt das Wasser her
wie schaffe ich das halbwegs Energie
neutrale sprechen noch nicht mal von CO2
neutral oder nachhaltig überhaupt
hierher zu kriegen und da kriegt man da
keine Antwort mehr spricht die Idee ist
gut aber es gibt noch nicht die
technische Lösung wenn Sie technische
Lösung gibt führen wir die Debatte gar
keine Frage aber die technische Lösung
für eine e-batterie Heil ich auch nicht
für so gelungen wenn man sich überlegt
dass ein so ein Bagger sondern irgendwas
dass der dass das so ein Bagger ungefähr
1000 Liter Sprit braucht 12 Stunden 120
Tonnen Erde so um eine Tesla batter
herzustellen wenn das nachhaltig ist
aber glauben Sie Ihr Katalysator wer
nachhaltig die fahren mit der
Chemiefabrik und durch die Gegend und
das ist nicht entsorgungsfähig das ist
Sondermüll
oh mein Gott das Beste ist am Ende doch
wieder Radfahren und jemand der das
genauso sieht wie sie ist diese Frau die
wir Ihnen hier zeigen ihr Name ist Julia
Hamburg Julia Willi Hamburg heißt die
Frau sie ist 14 Ministerpräsidentin von
Niedersachsen zeigen wir Ihnen hier das
Bild doch aus dem Wahlkampf als sie mit
diesem Plakat Wahlkampf gemacht hat
jetzt ist diese Frau Kai Ebel sitzt bei
VW im Aufsichtsrat
ja habe ich auch nicht verstanden
ehrlich gesagt
die Expertise
das ist proports das dann da jemanden
haben
natürlich ist sie geeignet so eine so
ein Posten einzugeben weil sie
Verantwortung für ihr Bundesland
übernimmt und weil Volkswagen natürlich
ein ganz relevanter
Wirtschafts Player in Niedersachsen er
ist gar keine Frage ich sage Ihnen die
Arbeitsplätze in Niedersachsen
die Sache klingt ja fast zu komisch und
wahr zu sein mal etwas und ich will hier
gar keine Werbung irgendwie machen aber
Volkswagen würde ich sagen ist vielen
anderen deutschen
Automobilherstellern voraus wenn es
darum geht innovative Konzepte zu
entwickeln so und ich glaube dass das
Volkswagen gar nicht weh tut und dass
der Betriebsrat ist absolut aushält sich
auch kritisch steht vorzustellen
ich bin nicht befugt für VW zu sprechen
ich weiß dass die Firma ich weiß das VW
sehr sehr kämpft und ich bin entsetzt
dass man für solche wichtige Ämter 19
nimmt die wirklich nicht aber auch gar
nichts an berufliche Qualifikation
vorweisen können aber das ist ein
anderer
Art
diskutieren mir das ist das was
wird aber ganz kurz das ist jetzt hier
billige Polemik das Land Niedersachsen
ist mehr als Aktionär von Volkswagen und
zwar
Niedersachsen wird von Menschen
repräsentiert die gewählt wurden
demokratisch gewählt worden und die
sitzen jetzt im Aufsichtsrat wie das
immer Tradition eine Frau ist also das
ist doch man kann nicht also das ist
kritisieren dass wir es hinterfragen
weil es eine Frau ist das ist eine sehr
große Problem
jemand der ein autofreies Niedersachsen
möchte ist der ist die die richtige für
einen VW Autokonzern Aufsichtsrat
zumindest richtig dass darüber eine
politische Diskussion geführt wird
der Autos
nicht mag der sollte nicht in einem
Autokonzern im aussichtsratsraum
Millionen von von Nutzern auf der einen
Seite und auf der anderen Seite und
viele Arbeitnehmer die auch um ihre
Existenz Angst haben wie geht es
eigentlich weiter mit der
Automobilindustrie und sowas
verantwortungsloses dann zu machen das
ist schon problematisch trotzdem
dieselskandal vielleicht hat es geholfen
wenn im Aufsichtsrat eine Person
gesessen hätte die kritische geguckt
hätte und da muss man sich überhaupt mal
deutsche Aufsichtsräte angucken dafür
ist der zuständig das hätte man in der
vergangen können die Frage ist ob jemand
richtig aufgehoben ist der das gar nicht
will der das Auto gar nicht mag Frau
Kappe das ist doch eine Frage mit der
sich auseinander hat die Politiker doch
genauso gewusst die sitzen ja mit dem
gleichen Wort
für Niedersachsen im Aufsichtsrat sitzen
dann waren sie offensichtlich weniger
am Aufsichtsrat von VW sitzen sondern ja
das ist doch ein weltumspannender
Konzern der unheimlich viele ja
erfolgreicher aber
kritische Distanz mit kritischer Distanz
das ist so genau das Problem man hat zu
eng zu im selben Boot gesessen deshalb
ist unser riesiges Skandal passiert uns
allen das darf nicht passieren
ist Politikerin und es geht auch nicht
um autofrei ist Niedersachsen sondern es
geht um eine neue moderne
Verkehrspolitik die mit weniger Autos
auskommen muss und wir sehen
differenziert es geht nicht um Auto frei
das will keiner sondern es geht um
weniger und was machen wir dann
Innenstadt sie haben völlig recht was
machen wir im ländlichen Verkehr wie
kriegen wir die Menschen von A nach B
aber wir können uns nicht blind an einer
alte wunderbare Technologie es sind
deutsche Autos sind die besten
Dieselmotoren haben die besten
Dieselmotoren ich habe über Diesel auch
promoviert irgendwie über bankomotoren
habe ich da auch ein bisschen aus aber
irgendwann ist Schluss mit dieser
Technologie das weiß die Welt und
deshalb müssen wir jetzt Umsteuern wir
haben die Kompetenzen Weltmeister
aber wir müssen jetzt momentan wir
müssen jetzt sehen dass wir unsere
heimischen Märkte dazu tüchtigen genau
die Antworten von morgen jetzt zu
produzieren das haben wir mal definiert
Zeit und die Jahrhundertwende geschafft
das müssen wir wiederholen na dann
müssen wir nicht an was altem fest aber
was machen
Sie nehmen einfach Behauptung als Gesetz
weil sie sagen das ist eine Technologie
keine Zukunft hat und die Welt ist davon
los das ist aber nicht richtig ein paar
Zahlen ich habe China gesagt immer mal
Californien in Kalifornien über dem Jahr
2030 zum Beispiel der Diesel nach dem
jetzigen Plänen komplett generativ das
heißt nicht mehr CO2 belastend sein das
noch eine tolle Entwicklung
nachlesen das macht zum Beispiel Philips
606 ein Hersteller von mineralio das
sagt die kalifornische
Gesellschaft die das eben dort auch
einführt das wird weltweit gemacht ist
der Weg wir müssen neben der
Elektromobilität es schaffen dass wir
den Kraftstoff weltweit eben nicht mehr
auf Erdölbasis anbieten sondern auf
Basis entweder von modernen
Bio-Produkten im Reststoffen von mir aus
auch Pflanzen Abfällen damit auch keine
Krankheit ist gesund
war in dieser Woche abstimmen dass wir
eben
postversielle Mobilität fördern wollen
weil das ein wichtiger Schwerpunkt ist
der wir werden im Jahre
2035 immer noch 30 Millionen
Dieselfahrzeuge in Deutschland haben und
die müssen wir auch betankt werden und
die da wollen wir auch einen Beitrag zum
Klimaschutz leisten und da ist doch die
Frage wie kann man das machen und das
kriegen sie eigentlich nur hin indem sie
Diesel an den Markt bringen die einen
höheren Anteil von aber bringen Sie
einmal auf den Punkt das konnte er kocht
das konnte jede ganz klar sagen was ist
für Sie die Partei die den
Verkehrsminister stellt die
Zukunftstechnologie ist dass die
E-Mobilität oder sind das System
synthetische Kraftstoffe ja wir wollen
das gerade nicht festlegen wir glauben
nämlich nicht dass die Politik
entscheiden kann was die Technik von
morgen ist sondern das wollen wir den
Menschen überlassen die sich damit
auskennen ja die haben ja gigantische
Summen an fördern deshalb sagen
wir ja auf europäischer Ebene ist der
verbrenner motor nicht tot sondern er
soll weiser existieren er soll eben mit
anderen Kraftstoffen befüllt werden das
ist unsere Politik wir diskutieren doch
jetzt hier als wenn wir diejenigen
werden die die ganze Welt versauen und
wir Deutschen müssen wieder mit hoch
Kopf vorne dran marschieren und sagen
wir retten die Welt wir machen es
richtig wir kommen jetzt mit
nachhaltigen Autos und wir tragen doch
wenn ich das richtig gehört habe darf
ich eben Ausreden ich möchte noch nicht
so schreien meine Stimme
1,8% haben wir glaube ich am gesamten
CO2-Ausstoß den verursachen wir dann
würde ich sagen dann fangen wir doch mal
vielleicht mit Amerika anfangen mit
China an mit Indien also ich war in den
Ländern ja auch viel unterwegs was da
alles auf den Straßen rumfährt was da
hinten drauf kommt also da wird mir
wirklich schlecht da merkt man auch
schon die Luft also da sind wir nicht
die ersten die vorne weg marschieren
müssen ist meine Vorbild sein wir sind
doch ja weil
auch Märkte definieren können weil wir
mal die besten Techniken hatten sogar
das ist doch wir können doch jetzt mal
die Zeichen der Zeit erkennen das heißt
wir müssen natürlich auf synthetische
Kraftstoff da ist doch keiner dagegen
regenerativ geschafft
Klasse wir dieses Fenster haben jetzt
haben wir die Euro 7 Debatte jetzt aber
wir müssen runter mit den Emission wir
haben ein Urteil des bundesver oder ein
Beschluss des Bundesverfassungsgerichts
das ist ja gut ja wir müssen aber runter
mit den Emissionen wir müssen da runter
der Verkehr hat es bisher nicht
geschafft und ein großer Teil sind die
Verbrenner und wenn wir es schaffen bei
uns dieses zu schaffen mit modernen ne
damit weniger weil wir dann als Vorbild
von der Welt auch Anerkennung und dann
unsere merken
wollen
die Funktion gehört dann auch dass
unsere Arbeitsplätze ganz vorbildlich
gestrichen sind und mittlerweile in
China sind dass unsere Vorbilder ich war
lange ich war zehn Jahre lang in der
nationalen Plattform elektromotiv jetzt
hat die MPM gegeben es gibt ja sehr
viele mehr Experten als wir hier am
Tisch sind die seit ungefähr 15 Jahren
darüber nachdenken inklusive Metall der
Arbeitgeber der Politik und wir haben
einen gemeinsamen Pfad aufgemacht dass
wir wenn wir jetzt in die neuen modernen
Technologien aber autonomes fahren wir
mal ein Thema hinein investieren würden
mehr Digitalisierung machen el maskmas
hervor Software schlägt Hardware bei uns
in der Industrie ist noch hart wäre
schlecht Software müssen also
Produktionsprozesse umstellen wir müssen
effizienter produzieren wir müssen mit
weniger Autos mehr Dienstleistungen
schaffen dann werden wir unterm Strich
mehr Arbeitsplätze erhalten und sogar
mehr schaffen als wir wenn wir
festhalten an einer Verbrenner
Technologie die deutlich zurückgehen
wird das ist nicht nur im Emission geht
sondern darauf einfach nur mal den
Individualverkehr abzusehen er wird das
ist genau unterschiedlich
darüber streiten wir gleich weiter nach
einer ganz kurzen Pause denn auch heute
ist ein Berlin hier ums Eck 200 m von
hier entfernt eine Straße zur
Fahrradstraße umgerüstet worden darüber
streiten wir gleich weiter hier bei Bild
nach einer ganz großen
der Kampf ums Auto den Fechten wir heute
Abend aus bei Bild die richtigen Fragen
und wir streiten mit der Berliner Grünen
Antje carpek die stolz ist darüber dass
immer mehr Straßen in Berlin zu
Fahrradstraße werden ja da bin ich stolz
drauf ich glaube das ist wichtig ist und
das zeigen viele andere europäische
Städte also wenn ich den Verkehr
ordentlich sortiere ist eigentlich mehr
eine Frage von deutscher Ingenieurskunst
ist und weniger von Ideologie in dem
Moment wo ich einen klaren Weg für den
Fußgänger für den Autofahrer für den
Radfahrer hat kommen die sich
gegenseitig weniger in die Quere ich
habe weniger Unfalltote und es so sorgt
für weniger Stress insofern kann ich nur
sagen ich verstehe die Debatten die hier
sehr emotional und mit Ideologie und
kulturkampfbegriffen gefühlt werden
nicht weil wenn ich mir zum Beispiel die
Holländer angucke die seit über 20
Jahren von einer liberalen Partei
geführt werden da fährt jeder Mensch
Fahrrad geht jeder zu Fuß fährt jeder
Auto fährt jeder öffentlichen und das
wird als eine rationale Entscheidung
wahrgenommen die ich morgens treffe je
nachdem wie mein Verkehr
in der Friedrichstraße in Berlin konnte
man sich nicht mehr aussuchen da durfte
man nur noch mit dem Fahrrad fahren bis
das Gericht kam und gesagt hat jetzt
dürfen wieder Autos fahren jetzt ist
aber die Nachbarstraße die
Parallelstraße in Berlin dann zur
Fahrradstraße gemacht worden also hier
wird das Auto nach und nach raus
gedrängt aus der Stadt ja also Berlin
ist ja ein fails Date also nicht nur da
sondern die können ja nicht mal Wahlen
durchführen und ich finde das
Verkehrschaos was hier in Berlin oder
Innenstadt ist eine Katastrophe also wer
hier im Auto unterwegs ist den beneide
ich nicht sondern das ist wirklich eine
Katastrophe wenn man jetzt so eine
zentrale Straße dicht machen will wie
die Friedrichstraße dann für das noch
mehr zum Chaos in der in Berlin Mitte
interessant ist Frau kapic wenn sie dann
diese Fahrradwege
einweihen wenn die eröffnet werden
sozusagen dann fährt die Berliner Grünen
Fraktionschefin dann doch mit dem Auto
vor und steigt für das Foto mal eben
locker aus Fahrrad um das war ein
glücklich oder ist das heuchlerisch nee
im Gegenteil sie hat es ja nicht
versteckt sie ist ja nicht drei Straßen
weiter umgestiegen er ist sie nicht
sondern sie ist direkt zu dem Termin mit
dem Auto gefahren weil sie es anders
nicht geschafft haben ich kenne ich
kenne aber Tina Yara seit fast 20 Jahren
und ich kann Ihnen sagen man trifft sie
egal wo immer auf so einem finde ich
nicht besonders schön Mountainbike und
das Haar fliegt weil sie einfach
fanatische Fahrradfahrerin ist sie hasst
es an ihrem Senatoren Job dass sie zu so
vielen Termin doch ab und zu mit dem
Auto muss aber wenn sie es muss
verheimlich weil es gehört das haben wir
vorhin das hat der Knies habe ich gesagt
es gehört einfach zur Lebensrealität
dazu das ist manchmal ähm so ist dass
man das Auto braucht und das gilt gerade
mal für Beschäftigte Minister aber das
ist genau der Punkt ob man ob man das
nicht ausblendet in der Politiker
wenn man mit dem Auto vorfährt um dann
aufs Fahrrad umzusteigen der Koch ganz
viele in Deutschland sind eben einfach
aufs Auto angewiesen in so vielen
zunächst einmal wir haben noch Einigkeit
ist doch toll wenn mein Fahrradwege
haben das eine gute Sache zu nutzen ist
eine wunderbare Ergänzung du sprichst
nichts dagegen alles funktioniert
eben ja gehört dass ich gesagt habe in
Holland sei alles so prima und ähm dort
wäre alles gut wenn sie nach Holland
gehen dann haben sie dort unglaublich
viele Tankstellen wo Sie heute schon CO2
neutralen Kraftstoff tanken können der
ist in ganz Europa gewünscht in
Deutschland ist er verboten es verboten
in Deutschland und das ist eine
skandalöse Entwicklung wenn sie in
Deutschland als Tankstellenbesitzer
sondern CO2 neutralen Kraftstoff
anbieten bekommen sie Post müssen Sie
rechts können wir durchkämpfen in
Holland haben Sie warum ist das verboten
das ist furchtbar ja
Nein sagen
dann stehen sie ganz leicht den
Verkehrsteil das was er gerade
dargestellt hat ist ja ein Produkt der
Vorgängerregierung ja also
und dass man die beiden Mischung aber
Herrschaft aber wann ist das Datum das
müssen wir jetzt in dieser Sendung
erklären wann ist das Datum wo sie
aufhören ist alles auf die Vorgänger
noch kannst du tun wie lange ja noch
kann ich es tun aktuell denn das Problem
ist ja tatsächlich dass die
Beimischungen von Diesel dass das im
Kern
hartriegeltiert ist und ist eigentlich
notwendig wäre dass man Biokraftstoffe
stärkt okay also komischen vorne ist
Ihre Kamera sie können jetzt im Sinne
ihres Verkehrsministers sind die FDP
Stellen versprechen wenn Sie diese
Auffassung sind das zu ändern das ist ja
die Kamera wenn die FDP bei der nächsten
Bundestagswahl die absolute Mehrheit hat
dann werden sie brauchen noch vier Jahre
dann sie stellen den Verkehrsminister
was bringt dann FDP
verlassen Verkehrsmeister sondern das
ist natürlich auch der Frage der
Umweltministerin beispielsweise die
Grünen stellen ja ist nicht nur eine
Frage des ftp-ministers und Sie können
mir glauben hat sie FDP nicht gegeben
dann wäre der Verbrennermotor ab 2035
tot in Deutschland
zu der politischen Debatte ein Herr Koch
machten Vorschlag der seiner Meinung
nach technisch technologisch sinnvoll
ist der Schäffler der Wirtschaftsexperte
der FDP sitzt daneben und nickt und sagt
er gut wir stellen zwar den
Verkehrsminister aber ändern können wir
auch nicht
das habe ich nicht gesagt ihr habt
gesagt natürlich haben wir was verändert
ja ich will es noch mal betonen auf
europäischer Ebene ist es möglich
künftig nach 2035 weiterhin
Verbrennungsmotoren vorzuhalten und die
auch mit synthetischen Kraftstoffen
beispielsweise zu sie sind tatsächlich
ein Quantensprung weil das viele
Tausende von Arbeitsplätzen in
Deutschland sichern wird also ich finde
das immer jetzt mal so aus dem Bauch
raus gesehen dass das ist alles irgendwo
nicht nicht schlüssig also man hat immer
irgendwo das Gefühl da ist so eine
unsichtbare Mehrheit im Raum die wünscht
da irgendwas wir müssen voranmarschieren
Deutschland geht vorne weg dann gucke
ich mal ja eigentlich hat uns niemand
dazu auch erkoren wir selber wir kommen
wieder auf die wir müssen das jetzt
machen wir stellen zwar fest dass
E-Mobilität alleine nicht funktioniert
reiten aber weiter diesen Weg gehen
immer weiter lassen Sie mich doch auch
mal ein bisschen
das sind doch die falschen Arbeitsplätze
dafür vielleicht also auf jeden Fall
sind diese ganzen diese ganzen können
nicht vernünftig entsorgt werden die
werden hergestellt
das ist richtig richtig
Fahrzeuge ja und wenn es so viele wären
wenn so viele wären wie sie gerne hätten
dann können wir jetzt hier gar nicht
auftauchen weil wir jetzt nicht überall
ausgehen soll
auf der Straße 3 Autos
nicht wissen erzählt aber nicht wir
sitzen natürlich wir haben gerade mal
eine Million wir wollen
e-batterie 1000 km fahren
Recht die alte Bundesregierung hat
festgelegt dass wir mindestens 15
Millionen bis 2035 brauchen um die
Klimaziele einzuhalten das ist das eine
wir brauchen ganze Strom herkommen
und wir wollen Industriearbeitsplätze
doch hier sicher wir wollen diese
moderne Industrie haben
nein die waren denn die Elektromobilität
aber Plätze waren dann gerade zu siehe
Tesla wenn wir Interessantes Gebilde
spielen dann kommen die 6000
Arbeitsplätze in Brasilien
in Deutschland gemacht
ist aber noch mal die waren eben auf der
Straße komplett
gar nicht neu hinzugefügt jetzt aber
noch mal kurz zur Straße weil wir gehen
ja wir wollen ja nicht nur über
Kraftstoffe reden das Auto in Berlin
nehmen wir mal das schöne Beispiel
Berlin hat tatsächlich 22% der Wege es
macht tatsächlich 40 % der
Verkehrsleistung es braucht aber 80% der
Fläche so das heißt wir müssen darüber
nachdenken wie die flächengerechtigkeit
stattfinden wie kriegen wir mehr Band
aber das ist aber anderen Städten auch
so eine andere europäische Städte haben
die meisten Menschen in Deutschland
wohnen auf dem Land ja Nein
und nicht mit einem so tollen
öffentlichen Verkehrsnetz wie hier in
Berlin der Knie was ist also das
Zukunftsmodell für die Altenpflegerin
die auf dem Land wohnt die ständig mit
ihrem kleinen eine Frau Betrieb über
Land fahren muss die ihre Patienten ist
versorgen muss es bleibt es bleibt auf
dem ländlichen Raum natürlich das Auto
das Auto wird aber in Sekundenschnelle
wird es natürlich zu einem öffentlichen
Verkehrsmittel weil die Frau und auch
viele andere können müssen nicht alleine
durch die Gegend fahren sondern man kann
ratzfatz auf digitalen Plattform
wunderbar ich selber ich ganz allein
selber ob ich Menschen mitfahren lassen
kann oder nicht das heißt wenn wir auch
am ländlichen Raum die Autos dieser Zeit
liegt das einzige Verkehrsmittel davon
machen muss es nicht machen aber es gibt
ja viele Leute die sehr gerne andere
Leute mitnehmen wir haben unglaublich
viele drei Möglichkeiten auch am Ende
drauf
machen weil weil meine meine
Alltagserfahrung spricht dagegen dass
das funktionieren kann
das ist jetzt sicherlich eine extremes
Beispiel aber die Altenpflegerin sagen
sie die über Land fährt die kann
Carsharing machen
die Macht kleiner Unterschied die wird
immer mit ihrem Auto fahren kann
in diesem Bereich aber das ist natürlich
wirklichkeitsfremd das wird in meiner
Region in dieser Form nicht geben die
Menschen morgen individuell 30 40
Kilometer zur Arbeit fahren müssen
unterschiedliche Zeitpunkte haben wann
Sie genau wann Sie Feierabend hast das
größte Problem das Experiment machen den
nächsten Jahren das wird nicht
funktionieren das wirklichkeitsfremd das
mag in Berlin funktioniert meine in
Berlin gibt es mobilitätsmodelle die nur
da funktionieren naja Großstadt aber
viele Menschen wohnen eben nicht in der
Großstadt sondern leben auf dem Land und
da funktioniert das eben nicht und wenn
es funktionieren würde ist eben sehr
teuer ja wenn Sie eine Elektrofahrzeug
kaufen dann ist es eben auch teurer als
normales Fahrzeug gebraucht aber Eva
Zeugen die sind ja so nachhaltig
wir sprechen wie wird Mobilität auf dem
Land in Zukunft aussehen noch mal das
Beispiel Altenpflegerin die immer wieder
zwischen den Dörfern fahren muss wie
wird die sich in Zukunft bewegen anders
eigentlich für mich auch kein Motivation
ist sich hier so engagieren wir haben
denke ich bei der Industrie hat die
Aufgabe insgesamt gesellschaftlich dass
wir eine ökonomische ökologische aber
auch sozialgerechte Lösungen erarbeiten
sozialgerecht ungefähr die Hälfte
Menschen haben in diesem Land Einkommen
unter 2000 Euro nicht wie ich ein tolles
Einkommen von Steuer bezahlt von der
Bäckereifachverkäuferin sondern die
haben ganz geringe kein Auto mehr
leisten sie fällt der Polo jetzt schon
weg der Ford Ka ist weg der Ford Fiesta
ist weggefallen der Seat wie ist
weggefallen dass gut diese ganzen
unteren Fahrzeugen preiswerten Fahrzeuge
die eigentlich auch weil sie klein sind
besonders umweltfreunde sind die fahren
weg muss man sich und auch mal mit der
Gesetzgebung Auseinandersetzung damit
muss man auch mal anfangen sich mit
ökonomischen ökologischen Zusammenhängen
auseinandersetzen
gar keine kleinen Autos gar nicht mehr
gar keine bezahlbar waren
von den Politiker im Kompaktklasse a b
Segment wird so gut wie kein Geld
verdient bei den kleinen Fahrzeugen das
sind die Polos die Fabias die Fiesta als
relativ erfolgreich da wird kein Geld
verdienen nur noch im Luxus Segment
jetzt haben wir eine Gesetzgebung von
der Europäischen Kommission und die sagt
sie müssen im Jahr 2030 plus minus 45 g
CO2 pro Kilometer können diese Fahrzeuge
sind unter extremen kostenlos diese
sparsam Fahrzeuge die müssten sie nur
noch elektrisch machen elektrisch
rechnen sich das von vorne bis hinten
nicht auch der Tesla der erste
vollmundig angekündigt hat ein kompakt
das Modell zu bringen hat es
rausgezögert die fangen alle
elektrischen Fahrzeuge an irgendwo bei
35 bis 40.000 €, aber der kleine Mann
mit dem kleinen Geldbeutel der aber auch
mit seiner Familie in Urlaub fahren will
der wird kein Auto mehr finden weil es
sich nicht mehr rechne die regulatur ist
fallen auch vernünftige Familie
machen Autos zu luxushüter und Autos
werden für kleine Frau und den kleinen
Mann nicht mehr bezahlbar sind gerade
die Europäische Kommission adressiert
ich bin nicht die Europäische Kommission
ich bin Landtags Abgeordnete aus einem
Bundesland was keine Automobilindustrie
hat aber sie sprechen die gleiche
Sprache in die nutzt die gleichen
Argumente
sie unterstellen mir aber relativ viel
und das bedeutet
so dann ist die Antwort das natürlich
für die Krankenschwester ich immer eine
Lösung anbieten musste sie ist ihr
ermöglicht von A nach B zu kommen
Landtagsabgeordnete in einer Großstadt
ich weiß dass es Herausforderung auf dem
Land gibt aber ihre Erwartungshaltung
dass ich jetzt hier die Lösung für den
Kreis ost-lippe Westfalen biete das ist
die falsche so viel Zeit aber sie haben
gesagt
wunderbar plastischen Beispiel einmal
bleiben was ist die Lösung für die Frau
den Mann auf dem Land um Mobilität
bezahlbar zu halten
ich glaube das ist alternative
Mobilitätsformen braucht das wird an so
lange wir keinen vernünftigen ÖPNV im
ländlichen Raum haben und das ist
tatsächlich massives Problem den gibt es
nicht wenn der Bus einmal am Tag kommt
das Auto das ist
aber das sagt doch jeder also es ist ein
es muss ein sparsam nein das hat niemand
dagegen argumentiert aber jetzt hat
die die
impliziert das quasi die Regierung die
Autos für die für bestimmte Leute
finanzieren soll das auch mit kann ja
auch nicht die Lösung sein es kann auch
ein FDP finanzieren weil
genau das sagen ja die großen
Unternehmen funktioniert aber dann
können wir doch vielleicht zu dem Punkt
sie haben die ganze Zeit davon
gesprochen dass wir Arbeitsplätze
vernichten wollen nie wir wollen neue
Arbeitsplätze schaffen sie sagten vorhin
es sind die falschen Arbeitsplätze nee
es sind Ingenieurs Arbeitsplätze genau
aber das bedeutet auch dass die
Unternehmen Umsteuern müssen so und wenn
sie das nicht
das tun sie ja offensichtlich nicht
sonst würden wir nicht so viele bleiben
haben
falsch wenn man in etwas vorhanden ist
was man gar nicht weiterentwickeln muss
ein Verbrenner etwas rein tut was sauber
ist was auch sauber wieder rauskommt
Verkehrsminister
keine Verbrennungsmotoren der
Verbrennungsmotor ist nachhaltig eine
Lösung aber er kocht das stimmt doch
nicht
wird aussterben das ist Konsens nein
nicht ganz genau warum
übrigens
der größte Automobilhersteller der Welt
vorgestellt einen neuen wunderbaren
Fahrzeugantrieb extrem Spaß haben
Schiene noch mal schickt dich an hier
Weltmarktführer zu werden während wir
hier alles abbauen wir nach China der
wenn in Zukunft unser Antriebe aus China
importieren das kann doch nicht allen
Ernstes ihre Strategie hat eine
nachhaltige ganz ganz schnell
wie lange gibt es Mercedes noch hier in
Deutschland
ich hoffe lange ich hoffe lange aber
sicherlich werden viele viele Arbeiten
ins Ausland abwandern ich bin nochmals
kein unternehmensprecher ich kann das
nicht genau sagen ich bin also
entspannter kann ich sie fragen sie
können ganz ehrlich antworten
alleine zum Beispiel das nur mal die
Gesellschaft
macht mir Angst
wie lange noch und er sagt ich hoffe
noch lange was ist ihre Antwort
Automobil ist in Deutschland erfunden
worden ich hoffe auch dass wir noch
lange die Technologieführer sein werden
auch wenn die Politik die Technologie
vorgibt dann kann
das konkret wenn sie so vorsichtig
Antworten der Scheffler wird Daimler in
zehn Jahren noch geben in Deutschland in
15 Jahren ich hoffe schon aber die Frage
ist es auch noch so ein stolz sie hoffen
in 10 Jahren ist auch in zehn Jahren
noch ein so Stolzes und große
Unternehmen wie heute ja darum geht mit
50 50
gesagt und das Teilen ich sehe schon
durchaus kritisch
Daimler in 10 Jahren in Deutschland noch
gibt ganz kurz zum ganz kurz zum Schluss
verzeihen Sie was ist ihr Traum von
Mobilität von Verkehr in Deutschland
wenn sie bisschen voraus gucken was
wünschen sie sich was hier auf den
deutschen Straßen sich abspielt ich
wünsche mir tatsächlich dass wir unsere
Städte aber auch die das Land so bauen
dass Menschen ohne Konflikte und
stressfrei sich von A nach B ähm
fortbewegen können und dass ich die
Technologie so weiterentwickelt dass es
tatsächlich alles CO2 neutral
funktioniert und ich leg mich weiter gar
nicht fest weil ich weiß nicht was in
zehn Jahren an technologischer
Entwicklung vorhanden ist dass wir dann
auch weiter Millionen deutsche
Arbeitsplätze in der deutschen
Automobilindustrie haben werden ich
wünsche mir dass wir weiterhin Millionen
und doch viel mehr gute gut hoch gut
bezahlte Ingenieurs Arbeitsplätze gibt
und fahren Sie dann natürlich gerade
euch auch Bahnen aber bitte nicht in
umgekehrter Reihenfolge am Bahnsteig
gegenüber und das Bordrestaurant ist
fällt aus das meine auch dass die
deutsche
Diskussion ich danke Ihnen der Knie fürs
Kommen danke Frau carpek für die ja
möglicherweise einmal ein bisschen
schwierige Diskussionen heute für sie
haben sie tapfer durchgestanden danke
Herr Ebel der Scheffler und Herr Koch
wir sehen uns nächsten Montag um 22:15
Uhr wieder hier
[Musik]